i remember
when the uh paid in full
soundtrack slash rock rockefeller album
came out
it was like it was like a double disc
album
and that was the first time that i it
was the we are the champions record
yeah and the way the way dame brought
you in on that record
was so legendary and you just came
you caught a [ __ ] body and i think i
might have saw it was like maybe a video
you or something in chicago getting the
rockefeller chain put on you
uh it wasn't chicago it was somewhere it
was on stage though right yeah it was on
stage
yeah yeah it was that was that was a
dope vibe right there
shout out to the homie dane yeah how did
um talk about how your relationship with
rockefeller started
um just early on a little bit of
everything
uh i would say kanye dame and jay
ah in some form or fashion just just has
something to do with me being involved
with rockefeller of course
jay you know with him being who he is
and us doing what we did with like uh
you know uh is that your chick popping
tags right things like that
and then of course yay
having that vibe and bringing bringing
me along in that whole vibrating
even with that vibe with like dang with
the with the champions joint so yeah
that [ __ ] was crazy
everybody i was cool with all of them
was uh did you have a relationship with
kanye first because of the chicago [ __ ]
or did you guys not really
like have a relationship but before he
became kanye west per se
we was already cool he was already cool
yeah yeah we didn't kick it a lot or
nothing like that but we always was
around each other
especially on on the music scene you
know in chicago so so
yeah it was yeah it's crazy because you
you mentioned is that your chick and
and um popping tags those are some crazy
joints
crazy features is that your chick is
like i think that's one of those records
that gets forgotten in hip-hop you know
what i'm saying like we forgot we're
rocking that joint that joint is [ __ ]
through the shoulders
i'll be rocking this oh that [ __ ] is a
classic
man that's my joint i still i think it's
the hardest memphis bleak record
that [ __ ] okay shout out to i mean shout
out to bleak but that's
yeah shout out to the homie um so
who so originally what made you decide
to go to r i mean obviously at the time
it probably wasn't hard to make the
rockefeller decision because it's the
hardest crew in hip-hop at the moment
right yeah yeah we was rocking yeah
yeah i was loving it you know that whole
vibe to be around that team at that time
period was definitely a
a plus you know and then to be vibing
with them
was a whole nother thing so so it was
cool yeah what was um
give me like a rockefeller story man one
that like just being being around that
era being around hove during that time
something that we like people might not
know just like a
crazy experience that you had back then
um
just always uh weirded out at jay's
prediction ability how he would look up
and say
you know that slow jams was going to be
a hit and then it would it would happen
and then
like me writing is this the end that
song with
uh p diddy yeah and when i did that song
and and walking in the room with
jmp diddy chopping it up and we were
talking we started talking about the is
this the end joint
and i remember how how i was doing that
joint
i was faded right in that joint you know
so like real faded right right right and
i had some good weed that i never had
before
so i wrote that joint and everything so
he was in there talking about it and jen
was looking at him and he just looked
and said
he was he was high when you wrote that
one so it was just
but it was strange because i was real
high when i wrote that so
for some reason about the flow he knew i
was high